Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange focus channel.
This is just a quick mini video to
answer a frequently asked question that
I get on my channel and that is what is
a Lingua Franca.
Lingua Franca is a phrase that I use a
lot on the channel.
A Lingua Franca is a language that is
used for communication between people
who speak different native languages.
Here are a couple of examples,
situations of when a Lingua Franca is
necessary.
For example,
there are many languages spoken in a
particular area or amongst different
ethnic groups and they need the language
to communicate with one another.
Another example,
there is trade between two different
countries that have no common language.
Example,
three at a professional conference for
experts from different countries who
have different native languages on a
global scale.
The current largest Lingua Franca is
English,
but there are other various Lingua
Franca is on a regional level and on a
national level.
An example of a regional Lingua Franca
is the French language.
In Africa,
there are a lot of different languages
spoken in Africa and in a large portion
of the continent they use French as
their language of communication as their
Lingua Franca.
An example of a national Lingua Franca
is in Pakistan where there are various
different languages spoken,
but or Redo the national language is
used as the Lingua Franca between those
different groups.
And other similar situation is in
Philippines where they have to Lingua
Franca us kind of what they mixed the
two Lingua Franca.
Sometimes they have to gallog and
English and those are used as the Lingua
Franca between people from different
regions of the country.
Sometimes there are both National Lingua
Franca is and more local Lingua Franca
is within a country.
So if we take the example of
Philippines,
there is a region where Ilocano is the
main language.
So someone from the Ilocanos speaking
region meet someone from,
for example,
the BCO speaking region.
They'll probably use the national Lingua
Franca,
which is tagalog or English or use both
of them.
Uh,
but if that same person meets someone
from the Ilocanos speaking region who
speaks a different language,
like a minority language,
then they'll probably use that local
language Ilocano as the Lingua Franca
because just in that one region there
are various languages spoken.
So the Lingua Franca you use depends on
who you're speaking to.
So you're sort of leveling up.
If you speak to someone in your region,
you can't understand them.
Use that regional Lingua Franca.
If you speak to someone from a different
region used the national Lingua Franca.
So it sounds all kind of complicated,
but basically it means speak the
language that helps you communicate with
that person the best.
Yeah.
The term Lingua Franca itself comes from
the name of a language that was spoken
in this way in the Mediterranean region
for hundreds of years.
It was kind of a creole romance language
that had a lot of vocabulary from
different Mediterranean languages mixed
into it.
One English source from 1632 referred to
this language as bastard Spanish.
So to wrap up and clarify,
a Lingua Franca is a language that is
used for communication between the
speakers of different native languages.
I hope that clarifies things.
Thank you for watching.
Have a nice day.